Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
SHANDI STRUGGLED TO LEAVE
HER PAST AS A CLERK
AT WALGREENS BEHIND...
Shandi: I'M GOING TO DO
ANYTHING TO CHANGE MY LIFE.
Camille: WHAT ARE YOU
HEARING?
Yoanna: I DON'T TRUST YOU.
Tyra: WHILE CAMILLE SPARKED
TENSIONS WITH HER COMPETITORS,
AND SARA DISOBEYED
HER FATHER'S WISHES.
Sara: HE CONSIDERS
MODELING PROSTITUTION.
Tyra: MERCEDES KEPT
HER ILLNESS A SECRET
FROM EVERYONE.
AND IN THE LAST ELIMINATION,
JENASCIA WAS SENT HOME.
EIGHT GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
Catie: THE PAST ELIMINATIONS
I'M FEELING RELIEVED.
I'M FEELING DISAPPOINTED
THAT I LET MYSELF SLIP
DOWN THE RANKINGS.
I JUST REALIZED THAT I REALLY
NEED TO UP MY GAME.
Camille: I MEAN, THEY CAN
CHOOSE, LIKE, A MILLION
BLONDE-HAIRED, BLUE-EYED GIRLS
TO WALK DOWN A RUNWAY,
BUT BLACK WOMEN IN A SHOW
ARE FAR AND FEW BETWEEN, OKAY?
IT'S VERY COMPETITIVE.
IT'S, LIKE, THAT ONE TOKEN GIRL.
April: WELL, COME ON.
WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF MAGAZINE COVERS
DO YOU SEE AN ASIAN ON?
IT'S ROUGHER BEING AN ASIAN
THAN A BLACK WOMAN.
TYRA'S TOLD ME RIGHT UP FRONT.
Tyra: THE FASHION INDUSTRY
IS ALL ABOUT RACE.
April: REALLY?
Tyra: DO YOU SEE ASIAN GIRLS
ON THE COVERS OF MAGAZINES?
AND I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT LUCY LIU.
SHE'S AN ACTRESS.
SO YOU ENTERING
THIS FASHION WORLD--
YOU WOULD BE AN UNDERDOG.
April: BEFORE I DECIDED
TO ENTER INTO THIS INDUSTRY,
I NEVER REALLY THOUGHT
ABOUT MY ETHNICITY.
SHE SAID, "THERE'S LESS SLOTS
FOR YOU IN ANY RUNWAY SHOW,
EDITORIAL OF FASHION MAGAZINES
THAN ANY SINGLE OTHER RACE
YOU CAN EVEN THINK OF
RIGHT NOW."
I'M HALF JAPANESE,
AND I'M HALF CAUCASIAN,
BUT I'VE NEVER DONE ANYTHING
THAT MADE ME ASSOCIATE MYSELF
AS AN ASIAN.
Camille: I DON'T KNOW
HOW MUCH APRIL LIVES OUT
HER JAPANESE CULTURE
IN HER LIFE,
BUT HER JAPANESE HERITAGE
MIGHT BE THAT ONE THING
THAT'S GONNA GIVE HER THE EDGE.
Mercedes: THAT'S NICE--
LET ME SEE.
WHAT IS THAT?
Sara: IT'S FROM IRAN.
MOSQUES. IT'S HAND-PAINTED.
I AM SO PROUD
OF MY PERSIAN CULTURE,
BUT TO MY IRANIAN FAMILY--
MY FATHER, WHO'S MUSLIM,
A MODEL IS A WHORE.
Mercedes: I GOTTA
DO SOMETHING.
I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH LUPUS,
WHICH IS A CHRONIC ILLNESS THAT
ATTACKS YOUR IMMUNE SYSTEM,
ABOUT A YEAR AGO,
AND I DON'T WANT MY ROOMMATES
TO KNOW.
I HIDE EVERYTHING.
I TAKE PILLS UNDER THE COUNTER,
AND, LIKE, HURRY UP
AND DRINK SOME WATER.
I DON'T WANNA BE JUDGED.
I JUST WANNA BE AS NORMAL
AS EVERYBODY ELSE.
♪♪♪
Tyra: HELLO.
LOOK AT YOU.
WHAT YOU DOIN'?
OKAY, COME ON.
WHOO! WHOO!
I CAN'T GET OUT.
AAH!
(laughter)
Tyra: NOW I'M ALL HOT.
OH, MY GOSH. COME OVER HERE.
OKAY.
YEAH, WE NEED TO GET
YOU GUYS SOME DOUBLE DUTCH.
Mercedes: YEAH.
Tyra: OKAY.
SO I'M REALLY PROUD OF YOU ALL.
YOU GUYS ARE REALLY STRONG.
FROM NOW ON,
IT'S GONNA BE REALLY DIFFICULT
WITH THE ELIMINATIONS,
AND I CAN TELL AFTER JUDGING
HOW HEAVY THE WHOLE EXPERIENCE
OF THIS COMPETITION
IS REALLY WEIGHING ON YOU ALL.
SO I WANTED TO DO
A ONE-ON-ONE WITH EVERYBODY.
SO LET'S START WITH XIOMARA.
Xiomara: WHAT'S UP?
YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO TELL ME
THAT I SHOULD--
Tyra: I DO, ACTUALLY.
Xiomara: LET'S TALK.
Tyra: I LOVE YOUR TOUGHNESS,
AND I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO THIS FEMININE THING
THAT'S NOT NATURAL FOR YOU.
Xiomara: I WILL BE TOUGH.
Tyra: I JUST FEEL LIKE THAT
IS WHAT MAKES YOU SPECIAL.
Catie: I STILL NEED TO FIND
FIND COMFORT ZONE
WITH STILL BEING ME,
BUT NOT LOOKING LIKE PLAIN JANE.
Tyra: HOW ARE YOU HANDLING
YOUR STRESS AND PRESSURE?
Yoanna: BETTER. A LOT BETTER.
THE STRESS LEVEL IS NOT INTENSE.
I MEAN, I DO KINDA MISS MY MOM.
Tyra: MY MOM AND I
ARE LIKE THIS.
Yoanna: THAT'S LIKE MY MOM.
Tyra: MY MOM QUIT HER JOB
AND CAME WITH ME TO PARIS
WHEN I WAS 18,
AND SHE IS THE REASON WHY
I'M STANDING IN FRONT OF YOU
RIGHT HERE TODAY.
MY MOM IS MY ROCK.
Camille: OKAY.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
IN MY WHOLE ENTIRE LIFE
I HAVE EVER BEEN CALLED A DIVA.
Tyra: I SEE CAMILLE,
AND I SEE THE DIVA ATTITUDE.
THERE'S A CERTAIN LEVEL
OF HUMILITY, MODESTY
THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT PROVING TO
THE WORLD HOW GREAT YOU CAN BE
WITH THIS THING ON YOUR CHEST
LIKE, "I'M GOOD, I'M GOOD,
I'M GOOD."
IT'S A QUIET CONFIDENCE.
April: I BELIEVE MY CALLING
IN LIFE IS TO BE A SOURCE
OF INSPIRATION AND STRENGTH
TO OTHER PEOPLE, BECAUSE THAT'S
WHEN I FEEL SO GOOD.
Tyra: I LOVE THAT YOU
SEE YOURSELF IN THAT WAY,
ESPECIALLY AS A WOMAN OF COLOR.
YOU KNOW?
April: I HAVEN'T
BEEN CONNECTED
WITH MY JAPANESE HERITAGE,
AND I'M NOT GONNA
PRETEND I HAVE.
SO I'M NOT TRYING TO MARKET
MYSELF TO JUST ASIAN GIRLS.
Sara: IT'S JUST,
I WANNA ASK YOUR OPINION ON WHAT
I SHOULD DO ABOUT MY DAD,
BECAUSE HE'S LEAVING MESSAGES
ON MY CELL PHONE RIGHT NOW
AND CALLING MY MOM.
Tyra: DOES HE KNOW
WHERE YOU ARE?
Sara: NO, HE DON'T.
Tyra: HE DOESN'T?
WOULD IT HELP YOU IN ANY WAY,
WOULD IT GIVE YOU STRENGTH
TO TALK TO HIM?
Sara: TO TALK TO HIM
JUST LIKE...
Tyra: WHETHER IT'S
A CURSE-OUT OR A...
Sara: IT WOULD BE OVER
IF I TALKED TO HIM RIGHT NOW.
Tyra: IT MIGHT BE SOMETHING
THAT YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
MAYBE IN YOUR PHOTO SHOOTS
YOU ARE THINKING ABOUT HIM.
THERE'S AN ANGER,
BUT THERE'S MAYBE A SADNESS,
'CAUSE THAT'S WHAT I SEE
IN YOUR EYES WHEN YOU DO
PHOTO SHOOTS--IT'S A SADNESS.
Sara: REALLY?
Tyra: MM-HMM.
Sara: WOW.
Shandi: NOW I'M STARTING TO
SEE MORE, LIKE, SERIOUSLY,
I THINK I'VE GROWN MORE IN,
LIKE, THE PAST COUPLE OF WEEKS
THAN I HAVE GROWN, LIKE,
IN THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
AND IF I GO BACK HOME
TO, LIKE, MY LIFE...
Tyra: I DON'T WANT YOU
TO GO BACK TO YOUR LIFE BEFORE,
GOING,
"THERE'S ALWAYS WALGREENS."
Shandi: YEAH, EVERYONE'S
LIKE, "NO MORE WALGREENS
FOR SHANDI."
Tyra: LOOK AT THAT
AS YOUR PAST AND LOOK
AT THIS WHOLE EXPERIENCE
AS BEING YOUR FUTURE.
Mercedes: OKAY.
Tyra: WELL, ONE THING
I WANNA TALK ABOUT WITH YOU
IS ON THE LAST PHOTO SHOOT,
I FELT LIKE YOU HAD
AN ATTITUDE WITH PEOPLE.
Mercedes: REALLY?
Tyra: YOU KNOW,
SO THAT'S JUST...
Mercedes: THAT SHOOT,
THAT DAY, I WASN'T FEELING WELL.
YOU THOUGHT I WAS GIVING
YOU ATTITUDE?
Tyra: NOT ME,
JUST IN GENERAL.
Mercedes: HAVING LUPUS--
I DON'T FEEL WELL,
AND I'M TRYING TO HIDE IT,
AND I'M TRYING TO BE STRONG.
Tyra: IF YOU GET ELIMINATED,
IT'S NOT GONNA BE BECAUSE
YOU'RE TIRED AT WORK,
BUT IF I THINK THAT YOU HAVE
AN ATTITUDE AND YOU DON'T WORK
WELL WITH OTHERS, I'M GONNA BE
LIKE, I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
YOU KNOW?
SO JUST BE HONEST AND SPEAK UP.
OKAY?
Mercedes: I FEEL MYSELF
JUST DRAINING DOWN,
BECAUSE I'M THINKING NEGATIVE,
I THINK I'M GONNA DIE.
I THINK MY LIVER'S GONNA GO OUT.
I'M HAVING SHORT TERM MEMORY.
MY HAIR IS FALLING OUT.
I FEEL VULNERABLE. I FEEL WEAK.
I'M HIDING ALL THESE THINGS.
I'M JUST TIRED OF IT.
SO WE WAKE UP, AND WE GO
TO, LIKE, LOWER EAST SIDE
TO MEET THIS GENTLEMAN
BY THE NAME
OF STAN CHRISTENSEN
AND LEARN ABOUT OUR PERSONALITY.
Stan: HI. I'M STAN.
WE'RE WORKING TO GET THESE GIRLS
FAMILIAR WITH WHAT IT IS
ABOUT THEMSELVES THAT
OTHER PEOPLE IDENTIFY WITH,
SO THEY CAN TALK ABOUT
THEMSELVES COMFORTABLY WHEN
THEY'RE IN INTERVIEW SITUATIONS.
WHAT I'M GOING TO INTRODUCE
TO YOU IS THE MAGIC OF CHARISMA,
HOW YOU CAN DRAW TO YOU
THE KIND OF ATTENTION
THAT MAKES YOU STAND OUT,
THAT MAKES PEOPLE LISTEN,
THAT MAKES PEOPLE NOTICE,
AND THAT'S PRETTY ESSENTIAL
TO A MODEL.
Sara: YOU KNOW,
MODELING IS A PACKAGE DEAL.
YOU HAVE TO LEARN HOW
TO WALK A RUNWAY
AND PORTRAY YOURSELF
IN A CERTAIN LIGHT.
Stan: WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
GATHER SOME INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW EVERYBODY ELSE
PERCEIVES US.
Sara: WE ARE HANDED
SHEETS OF PAPER,
AND WE HAVE TO MARK OFF
ADJECTIVES THAT DESCRIBE
EACH ONE OF THE GIRLS,
AND HE'S GONNA HAND THEM
BACK TO THE GIRLS,
AND THEY GET TO SEE
WHAT WE SAID ABOUT THEM.
Xiomara: IT'S A LOT.
DO I HAVE TO SEE WHAT PEOPLE
THINK OF ME REALLY IN THE HOUSE?
"ADVENTUROUS, HEADSTRONG."
Yoanna: "STYLISH,
SOPHISTICATED."
Shandi: "QUIRKY, FRAGILE."
Catie: "SECRETIVE,
EMOTIONAL."
April: "RESPONSIBLE,
INTELLIGENT, SOPHISTICATED."
Sara: "KIND, EXOTIC."
Camille: "SUPERIOR,
RELENTLESS, HEADSTRONG, DEFIANT,
OUTSPOKEN, CUNNING, AGGRESSIVE,
OPINIONATED, DEMANDING
AND SINGLE-MINDED."
Stan: ANYBODY SURPRISED?
WHO FEELS ATTACKED?
OKAY.
Mercedes: CAMILLE WAS NOT
HAPPY WITH HER RESULTS.
SHE WAS, LIKE, SUCKING
HER LIPS AND ROLLING HER EYES.
Stan: CHARISMA IS ABOUT
THE WILLINGNESS TO DEAL
WITH PEOPLE'S JUDGMENTS,
OPINIONS AND CRITIQUES.
Camille: PEOPLE CAN SAY
WHAT THEY WANNA SAY,
THEY COULD FEEL
THE WAY THEY WANNA FEEL.
HONESTLY, LIKE, I COULDN'T
REALLY CARE LESS.
MY OBJECTIVE IS TO WIN.
Stan: THIS ONE'S
A LITTLE BIT MORE SERIOUS.
WE'RE GONNA DO A SERIES
OF EXERCISES IN WHICH
EACH OF YOU IS GONNA GET UP
AND TELL A LITTLE STORY
TO LET PEOPLE SEE
YOUR INDIVIDUALITY, WHO YOU ARE.
THE FIRST EXERCISE
GOES LIKE THIS.
"THERE'S SOMEONE IN THE WORLD
I LOVE, AND THE REASON
THAT I LOVE THEM IS..."
OKAY, COME ON UP.
Mercedes: OKAY, THE PERSON
WHO I LOVE MOST IS MY MOTHER,
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN THROUGH
SO MUCH WITH HER,
AND SHE LETS ME BE ME.
SHE LETS ME
BOUNCE OFF THE WALLS
AND BREAK DISHES, AND
SHE STILL LOVES ME
FOR WHO I AM, AND SHE JUST
MAKES ME FEEL GOOD INSIDE.
I'VE NEVER LIVED ON MY OWN
BEFORE, AND IT'S HARD,
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T BEEN
FEELING WELL, AND, YOU KNOW,
USUALLY MY MOM TAKES CARE OF ME.
Shandi: UM, I'VE GONE THROUGH
MY LIFE BEING, YOU KNOW,
THE BLACK SHEEP OF THE FAMILY
AND NOT HAVING ANYONE
TO TALK TO
OR EXPLAIN MY FEELINGS TO,
AND THE ONE PERSON THAT I LOVE
IN MY LIFE IS MY BOYFRIEND ERIC,
AND IT'S BECAUSE HE ACTUALLY
UNDERSTANDS ME MORE THAN ANYONE.
Xiomara: I CONSIDER SHANDI
MY FRIEND, AND I FEEL BAD,
BECAUSE SHE'S GOING THROUGH
A LOT RIGHT NOW.
Stan: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
"THE WORST THING
I HAVE EVER DONE WAS..."
Sara: THE WORST THING
I HAVE EVER DONE IS PROBABLY
NOT BE HONEST WITH MY FATHER
MY ENTIRE LIFE JUST FOR THE FACT
THAT HE DOESN'T APPROVE OF
A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT I DO.
BUT MY MOTHER SUPPORTED ME 100%,
AND... (voice breaking)
I LOVE HER SO MUCH.
Catie: MY HEART ACHES
FOR SARA, BECAUSE HER FATHER
WILL DISOWN HER
WHEN HE FINDS OUT
SHE'S DOING THIS.
April: SARA HAD TO DEAL
WITH SOME NEGATIVITY
IN ASSOCIATION
WITH HER HERITAGE.
I HAVEN'T.
Sara: (laughs nervously)
Stan: THAT IS WHERE CHARISMA
COMES FROM.
IT COMES FROM
PUBLIC SELF-ACCEPTANCE.
THE MODELS THAT SUCCEED DO SO
NOT BECAUSE OF HOW THEY LOOK.
THEY DO IT BECAUSE THEY LET
PEOPLE SEE THEIR INDIVIDUALITY,
WHO THEY ARE.
Mercedes: IT WAS A GOOD WAY
TO GET TO KNOW
WHAT EVERYBODY REALLY THINKS,
BUT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME
TO COME OUT
AND SHARE WHAT I'M FEELING.
♪♪♪
Xiomara: (laughing)
Shandi: 28, 29...
Xiomara: PEOPLE ARE
TRYING TO SLEEP.
Mercedes: I'M FEELING BAD
AGAIN, AND I'M TIRED,
AND I'M JUST TRYING TO JUST,
LIKE, KEEP ON PUSHING MYSELF,
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE LUPUS,
YOU CAN'T STRESS OUT,
AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO DO
IN THIS HOUSE, SO YOU KNOW,
I'M JUST TRYING TO STICK
IN THERE.
Shandi: MY MOM ALWAYS THOUGHT
THAT I LOOK LIKE A BOY.
Xiomara: NO, YOU DON'T.
Shandi: I WOULD, LIKE,
I USED TO WEAR, LIKE,
MY DAD'S, UM, ARMY PANTS,
BUT I, LIKE, CUT 'EM
AND MADE 'EM INTO SHORTS,
AND I WOULD COME HOME,
AND SHE'D BE LIKE,
"YOU WENT TO SCHOOL
LOOKING LIKE THAT?
YOU LOOK LIKE A... BUM."
MY MOM'S NOT HERE NOW,
SO I CAN JUST DO WHAT I WANT,
AND, YOU KNOW,
I DON'T HAVE ANYONE, YOU KNOW,
PUSHING ME DOWN ANYMORE.
Yoanna: HELLO, MR. ALEXANDER!
J.: WHAT'S GOING ON,
DARLING?
HEY.
Mercedes: J. ALEXANDER
IS THE RUNWAY DIVA.
HE TEACHES US HOW TO WALK.
Xiomara: AND HE'S COMING
OVER FOR DINNER, AND WE FIND OUT
THAT HE'S BRINGING
A SPECIAL GUEST.
J.: I'VE TRIED TO CALL HER,
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHERE SHE IS.
Yoanna: HI.
Mercedes: HELLO.
J.: HI, DARLIN'.
Suzannah: HI. HOW ARE YOU?
J.: HI, HONEY.
Catie: YOU'RE A PSYCHIC?
Suzannah: YES.
PSYCHIC INTUITIVE WORKS.
THIS WILL BE A LOT OF FUN.
Shandi: SUZE IS A PSYCHIC,
AND WE'RE GONNA GET
THIS PSYCHIC CONSULTATION.
Suzannah: THIS WILL BE FUN.
OKAY. I DON'T KNOW YOU.
I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT YOU.
Catie: I DON'T KNOW.
DOESN'T IT MAKE THE DEVIL
COME OUT OR SOMETHING?
April: HALF OF THE GIRLS
ARE, LIKE, KINDA FLIPPING OUT.
Yoanna: DO YOU HAVE A GIFT,
OR ARE YOU...
Suzannah: I HAVE A GIFT,
AND I TAKE IT FROM YOU.
WHATEVER YOU COME IN WITH,
I READ YOU, SO LET'S GO.
YOUR DATE OF BIRTH?
Mercedes: 8/24/81.
Suzannah: MERCEDES,
YOUR BODY'S TIRED.
YOUR MIND ISN'T.
SOMETIMES YOU WANT TO DO
MORE THAN YOU PHYSICALLY CAN,
SO YOU'RE GONNA BE STRUGGLING.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND THAT?
Mercedes: I DON'T KNOW.
Suzannah: SOMETHING'S
BURDENING YOU.
I CAN SEE IT.
YOU DON'T KNOW?
Mercedes: MNH-MNH.
Suzannah: OKAY.
Mercedes: SHE'S DEAD ON,
AND SHE'S JUST DOING THIS
WITH NUMBERS, YOUR BIRTHDAY
AND YOUR NAME.
Suzannah: CAMILLE,
I'M JUST GONNA LEVEL WITH YOU,
AND I DON'T CARE
IF YOU PUNCH ME,
BUT YOU PUT PEOPLE OFF.
Camille: I'M NOT, LIKE,
BITING MY NAILS, LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD. NOBODY LIKES ME."
Sara: HOW DO YOU SEE
MY FATHER REACTING TO ME
BEING A MODEL?
Suzannah: HE'S GONNA HATE IT,
BUT HE'S GONNA SECRETLY LOVE IT.
Sara: REALLY?
Suzannah: MAKE PEACE WITH IT.
LET IT GO.
YOU'VE COME THIS FAR.
IF YOU HAVE THE COURAGE
TO DO THIS, BELIEVE ME,
YOU'D HAVE THE COURAGE
TO GO FURTHER.
Sara: SHE READ ME
LIKE A BOOK.
IT WAS REALLY ODD.
Suzannah: APRIL,
YOU ARE DETERMINED TO BE
A TOP MODEL NO MATTER WHAT.
YOU WILL BE A TOP MODEL.
XIOMARA, SOMETIMES, I THINK
IT'S EASY TO BE YOUR FRIEND,
BUT I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG
YOU REMAIN FRIENDS WITH PEOPLE.
IT ISN'T SHALLOW.
IT'S SELF-PROTECTION,
BUT THERE ARE
SOME VERY GENUINE PEOPLE
THAT WILL STAY FRIENDS WITH YOU.
OKAY, SHANDI, THERE'S A LOT
OF ADDICTIVE BEHAVIOR
IN YOUR FAMILY.
Shandi: MM-HMM.
Suzannah: SEE, I THINK
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH SHANDI
IS SHANDI NEEDS FAMILY.
DOES ANYBODY HUG YOU?
YOU DON'T GET HUGGED?
Shandi: WELL, I MEAN,
HERE, I DO.
Suzannah: YES,
YOU GET HUGGED.
Catie: WE LOVE SHANDI.
Xiomara: I LOVE SHANDI.
Suzannah: SEE--
EVERYBODY LOVES YOU.
SO YOU HAVE FAMILY.
EVEN IN THE MOMENT,
YOU HAVE FAMILY.
THAT MAKES YOU VERY RICH.
A LOT OF ISOLATED
AND LONELY SOULS.
IT'S OKAY, SHANDI.
Shandi: (crying)
Sara: SHANDI BREAKS MY HEART
BECAUSE HER PARENTS TREATED HER
LIKE THE BLACK SHEEP
OF THE FAMILY.
IT MAKES ME VERY ANGRY AT THEM.
J.: COME ON,
GIVE MAMA SOME SUGAR.
Shandi: I'M NOT CLOSE
WITH PRETTY MUCH
ANYONE IN MY FAMILY AT ALL.
I COULDN'T GO
GIVE THEM A HUG.
I COULDN'T SAY, YOU KNOW,
"I LOVE YOU. I MISS YOU."
AND IT'S JUST REALLY, REALLY
HARD TO DEAL WITH.
(continues crying)
Xiomara: EVEN THOUGH SHANDI'S MY
CLOSEST FRIEND IN THE HOUSE,
I NEVER KNEW HOW HORRIBLE
HER RELATIONSHIP SHE HAD
WITH HER PARENTS, AND,
YOU KNOW, THE LACK OF LOVE.
♪♪♪
Catie: SO REMEMBER THIS--
GIRL, YOU HAVE NO IDEA HOW FAR
YOU CAN GO WITH YOUR LOOK.
April: YOU KNOW
HOW MANY PEOPLE SAID,
WHEN I TOLD THEM
I WAS TRYING OUT FOR THIS,
THE WORD "TOKEN ASIAN" TO ME?
Catie: BUT ACTUALLY,
THAT'S WHAT MAKES YOU STAND OUT.
April: EVEN MY MOM,
'CAUSE OBVIOUSLY,
SHE'S THE ONE WHO'S RESPONSIBLE
FOR ME BEING ASIAN--
SHE THINKS MODELS ARE
BIG-BOOBED, BLONDE-HAIRED
BARBIE DOLLS,
SO SHE DOESN'T LOOK AT ME
AND SEE A MODEL,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
Catie: WHOO-HOO!
Stan: HEY.
Catie: HI, SAM!
Stan: THIS AFTERNOON,
A SURPRISE GUEST
IS GONNA INTERVIEW YOU
ONE BY ONE, AND YOU'RE GONNA DO
YOUR BEST TO USE
WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT YESTERDAY.
BE CHARISMATIC, BE COMFORTABLE,
BECAUSE WHOEVER DOES BEST
IS GONNA WIN A SHOPPING SPREE,
SO...
Woman: (gasps)
Xiomara: I HEAR "SHOPPING
SPREE," AND I'M LIKE,
"WHERE AND HOW MUCH?"
Stan: SO THE DETERMINATION
OF WHO WINS THAT SHOPPING SPREE
IS BASED ON BEING YOU, OKAY?
I'LL SEE YOU.
Mercedes: I CAN'T IMAGINE
WHO IT IS.
ARE WE GONNA MEET THE PRESS?
♪♪♪
Xiomara: (laughing)
HEY, JANICE!
Janice: XIOMARA,
HOW YOU DOIN'?
YOU LOOK GOOD.
Xiomara: OH, GOD!
IT'S JANICE DICKINSON,
AND JANICE, YOU KNOW, LIKE,
TEARS YOU APART.
Janice: ARE YOU KIDDING ME
WITH THAT WALK?
YESTERDAY YOU WERE
TAUGHT HOW TO MAKE THE MOST
OUT OF YOUR PERSONALITY.
TODAY I'M GONNA ASK YOU
A FEW QUESTIONS
SO WE CAN GET TO KNOW
THE PERSONALITY INSIDE OF YOU.
WHAT'S THE CRAZIEST PLACE
YOU'VE EVER HAD SEX?
Xiomara: (laughing)
Janice: THE CRAZIEST.
Xiomara: UM,
IN A BROOM CLOSET
IN HIGH SCHOOL.
Camille: STUCK
IN A FERRIS WHEEL.
Catie: I'M A VIRGIN.
Janice: OKAY,
IF YOU COULD BE A JUDGE
AND ELIMINATE ANYONE,
WHO WOULD IT BE?
Camille: OOH,
THAT'S A HARD QUESTION.
Sara: RIGHT NOW
IT'D BE CAMILLE.
April: CAMILLE.
Xiomara: CAMILLE.
Yoanna: CAMILLE.
Janice: WHY?
Yoanna: BECAUSE
SHE'S A WITCH.
Janice: YOU SEEM TO BE
A LITTLE INTIMIDATED BY ME.
DO I MAKE YOU NERVOUS?
Camille: I LOVE YOU.
LIKE, PEOPLE MAY CALL YOU,
YOU KNOW, THE BITCH OR WHATEVER,
BUT IT'S JUST IN YOUR--
Janice: BITCH?
I DIDN'T SAY "BITCH,"
BUT ARE THEY CALLING ME A BITCH?
Camille: CERTAIN PEOPLE
MAY CALL YOU THAT.
Janice: YOU KNOW,
THAT WAS REALLY OFFENSIVE TO ME.
YOU KNOW, I'M A MEMBER
OF THE P.T.A.
SO, SARA, TELL ME WHY
YOU THINK YOU SHOULD WIN
THIS COMPETITION.
Sara: TO GIVE A GOOD IMAGE
OF MIDDLE EASTERN WOMEN.
SHE IS BEAUTIFUL. SHE'S EXOTIC.
SHE HAS AN OPINION.
SHE DOES NOT LET MEN
WALK ALL OVER HER.
Janice: I AM WOMAN.
Sara: I AM WOMAN.
Janice: THAT'S WHAT
YOU WANNA SAY.
Sara: YEAH.
Janice: SARA'S GOT
SO MUCH PERSONALITY,
AND SHE HAS SO MUCH DRIVE.
SHE SOLD ME.
APRIL, I'M GETTING A SENSE
THAT YOU'VE GOT THIS NEGATIVITY
TOWARDS YOUR ETHNICITY.
April: I'M HALF WHITE
AND HALF ASIAN, OKAY?
JUST BECAUSE I HAVEN'T
IDENTIFIED MYSELF AS AN ASIAN
OR AS A WHITE PERSON,
THAT DOESN'T MEAN
I'M REJECTING IT.
Janice: APRIL DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT TO CALL HERSELF,
SO THAT'S WHAT KINDA BOTHERS ME
ABOUT HER.
SHE CLEARLY LOOKS ASIAN,
AND SHE SHOULD BE PROUD OF IT.
IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT YOU'RE HIDING
THAT YOU'RE WORRIED
THAT WOULD COME OUT,
SHOULD YOU BECOME FAMOUS?
Shandi: PROBABLY THE DRUGS.
Janice: AND HOW DID YOU STOP,
OR HAVE YOU?
Shandi: I WAS, UM,
ARRESTED FOR, UM, ROBBERY,
AND I GOT ON PROBATION
FOR TWO YEARS.
I JUST LIKE BEING HONEST.
I'M NOT PRETENDING, "OH, YEAH,
I HAVEN'T DONE THIS.
I HAVEN'T DONE DRUGS."
IT'S LIKE A PART OF MY LIFE
THAT I WENT THROUGH,
AND IT'S, LIKE, IN MY PAST.
THE WHOLE TIME I'M DOING
ALL THESE STUPID DRUGS,
I WANTED MY PARENTS
TO ACTUALLY SHOW THAT THEY CARED
WHAT HAPPENED TO ME,
AND, YOU KNOW,
I WASN'T GETTING THAT.
Janice: SHANDI KNOCKED
MY SOCKS OFF WITH HER HONESTY.
Mercedes: SEEING JANICE,
I AM INTIMIDATED.
I'M AFRAID THAT SHE'S GONNA
BREAK ME DOWN.
Janice: MERCEDES,
LATELY I'VE NOTICED
YOUR ENERGY HAS GONE DOWN
A LITTLE.
WHAT HAPPENED TO MERCEDES?
WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU, GIRL?
Mercedes: I'M, LIKE,
OH, MY GOD.
SHOULD I TELL HER I HAVE LUPUS,
AND I HAVEN'T BEEN FEELING WELL
AND I'VE BEEN TRYING TO HIDE IT?
UM, I DON'T WANNA MAKE EXCUSES
THAT I HAVE AN ILLNESS,
BUT I DO.
UM, I HAVE LUPUS.
Janice: WHAT IS LUPUS--
TELL ME WHAT IT IS.
Mercedes: IT'S
A CHRONIC ILLNESS IN WHICH
YOUR BODY ATTACKS ITSELF.
Janice: DOES THAT
PULL AWAY FROM YOUR ENERGY?
Mercedes: IT DOES,
AND I'M TRYING REALLY HARD
TO FIGHT THROUGH IT.
IT'S JUST,
SOMETIMES I CAN'T CONTROL IT.
I MADE A HUGE DECISION.
I JUST SHARED A LITTLE PART
OF ME THAT I HAVE NEVER SHARED
WITH ANYBODY ELSE.
Janice: ALL RIGHT,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
COME ON IN, GIRLS.
TODAY I HAD TO JUDGE YOU
ON YOUR CHARISMA,
AND THE COOLEST THING
IS ADMITTING
THAT YOU HAVE FLAWS,
AND THAT'S WHAT MAKES SOMEONE
INTERESTING--
YOU KNOW, THE FACT
THAT YOU CAN BE HONEST.
APRIL, YOU'VE GOT THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL ASIAN FEATURES,
SO EMBRACE YOUR ETHNICITY.
EMBRACE THE FACT
THAT YOU ARE UNIQUE.
SARA, YOU GAINED BROWNIE
POINTS FROM ME.
WHY? BECAUSE THERE'S SOMETHING
ABOUT YOUR STANCE
ON WAVING A FLAG
FOR PERSIAN WOMEN.
I FELT THAT YOU WERE
BEING HONEST.
OH, SHAND-I BACK THERE.
WHEN YOU ADMITTED THAT YOU HAD
A RECORD, YOU KNOW,
ADMITTING SOMETHING
THAT BLEAK AND DARK,
WILL WORK AS A PLUS FOR YOU,
BECAUSE EVERYONE HAS A PAST.
AND THE WINNER
OF THIS COMPETITION
GOES TO MERCEDES.
Mercedes: OH, THANKS.
(applause)
Janice: YOU WIN BECAUSE
OF YOUR HONESTY.
WHEN YOU SHARED
THAT YOU HAVE LUPUS,
THAT'S WHEN YOU REACHED ME,
AND FOR SOMEONE TO BE
THAT STRAIGHT UP,
TO COME OUT AND 'FESS THAT UP,
WE CAN GIVE
GIRLS AND BOYS OUT THERE
FAITH, HOPE AND UNDERSTANDING.
Sara: I WOULD NEVER HAVE
GUESSED IN A MILLION YEARS
THAT MERCEDES HAD
ANY TYPE OF ILLNESS.
Janice: THAT'S WHY YOU WIN
A SHOPPING SPREE,
AND YOU GET TO CHOOSE ONE
PERSON TO GO ALONG WITH YOU.
Mercedes: OH, WOW.
Janice: THERE YOU GO.
Mercedes: I CHOOSE... SARA.
Sara: OH, MY GOD. THANK YOU.
Janice: YES, SARA.
Xiomara: THE FACT
THAT MERCEDES HAS LUPUS
DEFINITELY COMES AS A SHOCK
TO ALL OF US, AND THE FACT
THAT SHE'S WORKING THROUGH IT
ON HER OWN SAYS A LOT FOR HER.
Mercedes: NOW THAT EVERYTHING
IS OUT IN THE OPEN, I JUST HOPE
THEY'RE NOT GONNA USE MY ILLNESS
TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST ME.
I WON THE PERSONALITY CONTEST,
AND SARA AND I
ARE GOING SHOPPING.
Woman: WELCOME TO INTERMIX.
♪♪♪
Mercedes: THIS IS VERY, UH,
"FLASHDANCE."
THERE'S TONS OF STUFF
ON THESE SHELVES,
AND IT WAS VERY OVERWHELMING
TO CHOOSE WHICH ITEM I WANTED.
I SAW THE PERFECT PURSE FOR YOU.
Yoanna: COMING OUT WITH HAVING
LUPUS-- I THINK THAT'S
PRETTY COURAGEOUS.
Mercedes: I JUST SAID
WHATEVER.
IT'S EASIER TO JUST SAY IT
THAN TO HIDE IT, THAT'S ALL.
THANK YOU.
♪♪♪
Yoanna: OKAY, SO THE TYRA MAIL
COMES, AND IT SAYS,
"SINK OR SWIM,"
AND WE'RE KINDA CURIOUS
AS TO WHAT IS GONNA COME UP.
IN A WAY, WHEN I SAW
ACQUATICREATIONS,
I WAS RELIEVED THAT WE WEREN'T
GONNA GET THRUSTED IN
WITH SHARKS
OR SWIM IN SOME SEWAGE PLANT.
Jay: ALL RIGHT,
SO IT'S A FISH THEME TODAY,
OBVIOUSLY.
WE ARE GOING TO DO A SHOOT
FOR QUENCH WATER.
Camille: OKAY,
ALL I COULD THINK ABOUT IS
THERE'S STILL BACTERIA,
AND FISH USE THE BATHROOM.
IT WAS JUST LIKE, WHOA.
Jay: I WANNA INTRODUCE YOU
TO ONE OF THE TOP
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHERS--
GEORGE HOLTZ.
George: MORNING, GIRLS.
Women: MORNING.
Jay: SO THESE ARE
YOUR EIGHT GIRLS.
GEORGE HAS SHOT
OUR VERY OWN MISS TYRA BANKS,
AND RECENTLY ADRIANNE CURRY
FROM "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
YOU'LL NEVER MEET ANYBODY
MORE FABULOUS THAN NOLé MARIN.
THIS IS YOUR WORLD TOP
WARDROBE STYLIST FOR TODAY.
AND THIS IS MINI.
Nolé: AND SHE'S READY
FOR THE DAY, BABY.
COME ON.
♪♪♪
Nolé: WE NEED CHIFFON
ALSO, GUYS.
♪♪♪
Sara: THIS PHOTO SHOOT, IN
PARTICULAR, IS VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE TYRA TOLD ME THAT
SHE COULDN'T SEE
A LOT OF FEELING IN MY EYES,
AND I'M PRAYING TO GOD
THEY SEE THAT.
Jay: THIS IS NOT A CHALLENGE
FOR HOW LONG YOU CAN HOLD
YOUR BREATH.
George: AND JUST TRY TO STAY
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE TANK,
AND MAKE SURE YOU MAKE IT
LOOK GOOD.
YOU KNOW WHAT? JUST GET IN.
George: TOO MANY BUBBLES.
WE'RE GETTING A LOT OF
BUBBLES-- ALL RIGHT?
AND TRY TO STAY DOWN LONGER--
OKAY, GO.
I NEED TO SEE THAT
FACE MORE, ALL RIGHT?
YOU NEED TO TWIST AROUND
SO YOU LOOK INTO THE CAMERA
A LITTLE MORE, ALL RIGHT?
GO FOR IT. WOW, NICE.
Jay: EYES ARE
TEN TIMES BETTER.
Nolé: THAT WAS--
THAT WAS GORGEOUS.
Jay: THAT LOOKS BEAUTIFUL.
Nolé: NOW YOU'RE WORKIN' IT.
Jay: LISTEN UP,
YOU GUYS GOT COMPETITION.
MISS SARA--SHE WAS BETTER
IN THE WATER
THAN SHE WAS ON LAND.
Nolé: THAT'S RIGHT.
George: GO AHEAD.
OKAY.
DON'T BE A PUFFER FISH.
George: NICE.
Catie: YAY!
George: LOVE THE DRESS.
GORGEOUS.
Nolé: GETTIN' DANGEROUS
IN THERE.
THERE'S SOME SHARKS
IN THAT WATER.
CAMILLE, DON'T BE SCARED.
Camille: OKAY,
I'M CARIBBEAN.
MY FAMILY IS FROM JAMAICA.
LET ME JUST THINK ABOUT
I'M THE OCEAN.
♪♪♪
Jay: ALL RIGHT-- TRY AND BE
A LITTLE MORE ETHEREAL.
RIGHT NOW I'M GETTING TOO,
"UNH-UNH-UNH-UNH."
♪♪♪
Jay: CAMILLE GOT
IN THAT TANK, AND I WAS JUST
EXPECTING AMAZING.
SHE GAVE ME KIND OF THIS, LIKE,
DRAG QUEEN VOGUE.
ARE YOU NERVOUS?
Xiomara: A LITTLE BIT--
A LITTLE BIT.
Jay: WHY?
Xiomara: 'CAUSE I USUALLY
HOLD MY NOSE UNDERWATER.
Jay: WHAT YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO REALIZE IS
IT'S MORE ABOUT BREATHING,
EXPELLING THE AIR,
AND THEN JUST KIND OF
SINKING IN.
YOU DO A LOT OF MOVING AROUND.
WE GET TOO MANY BUBBLES,
WE CAN'T USE THAT FRAME.
Xiomara: IT'S GONNA BE
INTERESTING TO SEE ME
HOLDING MY BREATH
WITHOUT USING MY HANDS.
I'VE TRIED IT,
AND WATER GOES ALL UP
IN MY NOSE.
Jay: SHE'S GOTTA LEARN
TO KEEP HER EYES OPEN.
George: MUCH SLOWER.
MORE GRACEFUL. DON'T PANIC.
YOU GOTTA REALLY CONCENTRATE
ON KEEPING THOSE EYES OPEN.
Jay: YOUR EYES ARE CLOSED
IN EVERY SHOT.
YOU GOTTA LEAVE THEM WIDE OPEN.
IT'S GONNA STING A LITTLE,
BUT JUST GET USED TO YOUR EYES
JUST BEING OPEN UNDERWATER.
Nolé: XIOMARA--
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS GIRL,
BUT SHE LOOKED LIKE A WALRUS
WEARING CHIFFON.
April: I'M TRYING
TO KEEP DOING MY BEST,
NOT FOCUS ON EVERYONE AROUND ME
AND HOW THEY'RE DOING,
AND JUST FINISH THIS RACE
ON TOP.
George: NICE. WOW.
IT'S LIKE--
HOW DOES SHE STAY DOWN SO LONG?
SHE'S LIKE THE EVEREADY BUNNY.
SHE JUST KEEPS GOING.
Jay: YOU DON'T HAVE TO
STAY DOWN THERE THAT LONG
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO--
IT'S OKAY.
April: YOU KNOW WHAT?
ACTUALLY, I'M--
Jay: IT'S FINE?
Nolé: APRIL IS LIKE
"CROUCHING TIGER,
HIDDEN DRAGON," "THE MATRIX."
SHE WAS FABULOUS.
Jay: ALL RIGHT, WE'RE READY.
OKAY, YOU CAN GO DOWN, SHANDI.
Nolé: SHE LOOKS CONSTIPATED.
George: HOLD ON A SEC.
Nolé: FROM THE NECK UP,
IT DOES NOT WORK.
Shandi: (coughs)
Jay: YOU ALL RIGHT?
Nolé: SHANDI--
SHE LOOKED PETRIFIED, SCARED,
JUST LIKE A DROWNING CHICKEN.
Mercedes: LUPUS GOES
THROUGH REMISSIONS AND FLARES.
ONE DAY, I'LL BE
REALLY, REALLY TIRED,
AND THE NEXT DAY
IT'LL BE NORMAL FOR TWO DAYS,
BUT RIGHT NOW
I'M FEELING BETTER.
George: WANNA GO DOWN MORE
TO SEE HOW YOU LIKE IT?
George: BEAUTIFUL. WOW.
GORGEOUS.
Nolé: SHE GAVE YOU
WATER COUTURE, HONEY.
THAT WAS WATER COUTURE
ALL THE WAY.
Mercedes: I'M PROUD BECAUSE
I PROVED TO MYSELF,
AND IT'S LIKE GLORIA GAYNOR
SAYS, I WILL SURVIVE
IN THIS COMPETITION.
♪♪♪
Catie: HEY, MERCEDES AND
SARA, COME HERE.
"AS PART OF YOUR CHALLENGE
WIN, A SPECIAL GIFT
IS ARRIVING FOR YOU."
Sara: SHUT UP.
Mercedes: ARE YOU SERIOUS?
I JUST RECEIVED
A SHOPPING SPREE.
WHAT ELSE CAN I RECEIVE,
JEWELRY, DIAMONDS?
I'M THINKING,
I DON'T NEED ANYTHING ELSE.
Catie: AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
THE ELEVATOR DOOR OPENS UP...
Sara: OH, MY GOD!
Catie: AND IT'S THEIR MOMS.
Mercedes: I'VE MISSED YOU!
Sara: OH, MY GOD!
Mercedes: SO MANY EMOTIONS.
EVERYTHING I'VE BEEN
GOING THROUGH, I JUST LET IT OUT
WHEN I HUGGED HER.
Sara: OH, MY GOD!
NO, THIS IS JUST, LIKE,
NOT HAPPENING, BUT IT IS.
MY MOM'S RIGHT THERE
IN NEW YORK.
OH, MY GOD.
April: SARA AND MERCEDES,
TO ME, HAVE SUCH
AN ETHNIC, FUNKY, TRENDY LOOK,
AND HERE ARE THESE, LIKE,
BLONDE HAIR, WHITE MOMS.
Sara's mother: HI.
Sara: APRIL.
April: BUT I'M USED TO THAT,
BECAUSE YOU LOOK AT MY DAD,
AND YOU LOOK AT ME,
AND IT'S LIKE,
"THAT'S YOUR DAUGHTER?"
'CAUSE HE LOOKS LIKE
ART GARFUNKEL.
Tyra: HEY! MY MAMA'S HERE.
Camille: AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
I HEAR, "AAH!"
AND IT'S TYRA'S MOM,
AND SHE WAS LIKE,
"EVERYBODY, COME,
GIVE ME A HUG."
Mercedes: TYRA'S MOM
COMES OVER, AND WE SIT DOWN,
AND SHE, UH, TELLS US ABOUT
HOW TYRA GOT INTO THE BUSINESS.
Carolyn: SHE GRADUATED
FROM HIGH SCHOOL AT 17,
AND THAT SEPTEMBER,
I STOOD IN THE AIRPORT
AND CRIED UNTIL I WAS SICK.
(laughing)
WAVING AT THE PLANE TAKING OFF.
BY THE TIME SHE LEFT
TO GO TO PARIS,
SHE WAS FULLY
KNOWLEDGEABLE OF EVERYTHING,
INCLUDING THE NEGATIVITIES.
SHE IT TOOK AS A BUSINESS, NOT
AS,"OH, I'M GONNA RUN OVER HERE
AND HAVE SOME FUN
AND BECOME 'FAMOUS'."
SHE DOESN'T GET INVOLVED
WITH DRUGS OR PARTYING
OR THE WRONG MEN.
YOU TRAVEL THE WORLD,
AND YOU'RE IN HOTEL ROOMS ALONE.
YOU TRAVEL TO THE NEXT COUNTRY,
YOU'RE IN AN AIRPLANE--
LOTS OF PEOPLE AROUND YOU,
BUT BASICALLY ALONE.
THAT'S HOW A LOT OF GIRLS
GET IN TROUBLE.
WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO IS
KEEP A STRONG CONNECTION
TO THE PEOPLE WHO WILL BE THERE
WHETHER YOU WIN
OR WHETHER YOU LOSE.
Tyra: I HOPE YOU ALL
SEE YOUR CAREERS AS MORE THAN
JUST BEING CUTE IN MAGAZINES.
YOUNG GIRLS TODAY
HAVE SUCH LOW SELF-ESTEEM,
SO I STARTED A CAMP
CALLED TZONE.
Y'ALL, WHEN I WAS A KID,
I WAS SUPER SKINNY
AND SO INSECURE,
SO I REALLY IDENTIFY
WITH MY GIRLS.
EVERY NIGHT WE TALK ABOUT THINGS
LIKE RELATIONSHIPS AND SEX
AND BEAUTY AND BODY IMAGE.
SO AS A TOP MODEL,
YOU GUYS REALLY CAN INFLUENCE
AND INSPIRE.
NOW IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
TO LOOK AT YOUR MODELING CAREER
AS A BUSINESS.
THIS INDUSTRY ONLY ALLOWS
FOR ONE PERSON OF COLOR
IN THAT CERTAIN CATEGORY
AT A TIME.
SO, LIKE, APRIL, IF YOU MAKE IT,
YOU KNOW, YOU ARE THE TOP
ASIAN GIRL AT THE MOMENT,
OR CAMILLE OR, YOU KNOW,
XIOMARA, YOU GUYS ARE THE TOP
"BLACK" OR "LATIN" GIRLS.
Sara: I MAY NOT LOOK
FULLY MIDDLE EASTERN,
BUT I'D LIKE TO REPRESENT
A GOOD IMAGE
FOR MIDDLE EASTERN WOMEN.
April: NOW I REALIZE
YOU CAN'T TAKE IT PERSONALLY.
I'M VERY BUSINESS-MINDED.
I UNDERSTAND THAT, YES, MY LOOK
IS MUCH MORE DOMINANTLY ASIAN
THAN WHITE, THEREFORE I MUST
MARKET MYSELF THAT WAY
TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
Tyra: BYE!
Women: BYE!
Xiomara: TYRA'S MOTHER
IS SO CUTE.
I FELT AS IF MY MOM WAS HERE
IN SPIRIT.
Sara's mother: IT'S HARD
TO SAY WITH YOUR DAD.
YOU HAVE NO CONTROL OVER
WHAT HE THINKS
AND SAYS OR ANYTHING, HONEY.
YOU KNOW THAT IT'S CULTURAL.
SARA, THEY LOVE YOU--
THEY'RE NOT GONNA HATE YOU.
THEY'RE GONNA BE SO HAPPY
FOR YOU.
DON'T BE AFRAID OF IT.
YOU EARNED THIS.
SO JUST GET OUT THERE
AND BE SARA.
Sara: MY MOM HAS JUST
INCREASED MY CONFIDENCE
ABOUT A MILLION PERCENT.
Shandi: WATCHING, YOU KNOW,
MERCEDES AND SARA, IT'S LIKE,
THEIR MOMS KNOW THEM
THROUGH AND THROUGH,
AND OF COURSE, IT MAKES ME SAD.
IT MAKES ME THINK ABOUT HOW
I'M NOT THAT WAY WITH MY MOM.
Mercedes: WELL, I ASKED HIM,
LIKE, HOW MANY PEOPLE, YOU KNOW,
HAVE RECOVERED FROM THIS--
AND HE'S LIKE--
Mercedes' mother:
NOBODY RECOVERS-- IT'S CHRONIC.
YOU'LL NEVER GET RID OF IT.
Mercedes: I KNOW, BUT--
Mercedes' mother: I KNOW
YOU DON'T WANNA HEAR THAT,
BUT THAT'S THE REALITY, SO...
Mercedes: SORRY.
IT JUST SUCKS, 'CAUSE, YOU KNOW?
Mercedes' mother: I KNOW--
I KNOW IT'S SUCKS.
Mercedes: (crying)
Mercedes: IF I SHOW GOD
AND MY FAMILY
THAT I CAN BE STRONG,
THAT NOTHING COULD HURT ME
WITH THIS DISEASE.
I WANNA GO AS FAR AS I CAN,
YOU KNOW?
Sara's mother: TAKE CARE.
BYE-BYE.
Shandi: JUST SEEING HOW MUCH
THEY'VE BEEN THERE
FOR EACH OTHER,
AND THAT THEY'RE A REAL FAMILY
AND THEY LOVE EACH OTHER...
Sara's mother: BYE, GUYS!
Shandi: EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE IN A COMPETITION,
AND WE'RE TRYING TO BEAT
ONE ANOTHER, WE'RE A FAMILY.
ONE OF US IS GOING TO GO HOME
TOMORROW.
IT MAKES ME SAD.
Tyra: HELLO, EVERYBODY.
Yoanna: HELLO.
Catie: HELLO.
Tyra: NOW IT'S TIME TO MAKE
OUR FIFTH ELIMINATION
TOWARDS DETERMINING WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE WINNER WILL RECEIVE
A CONTRACT
WITH MY MODELING AGENCY--
IMG MODELS,
A PHOTO SPREAD
IN "JANE" MAGAZINE
AND A COSMETICS CAMPAIGN
WITH SEPHORA.
AND WE HAVE
OUR PANEL OF JUDGES HERE.
FIRST, WE HAVE
MISS JANICE DICKINSON.
SHE IS
THE VERY FIRST SUPERMODEL.
WE HAVE ERIC NICHOLSON-- ERIC IS
THE SENIOR FASHION EDITOR
AT "JANE" MAGAZINE.
NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
WE HAVE OUR SPECIAL GUEST JUDGE.
NOLé MARIN IS YOUR STYLIST
ON YOUR UNDERWATER SHOOT.
Nolé: AND EMPRESS MINI,
AS YOU ALL KNOW.
(Mini barks)
Tyra: SO WE'RE GONNA BRING
YOU IN ONE BY ONE
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE,
AND WE'LL DETERMINE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
SHOULD BE ELIMINATED.
Janice: THIS WEEK
YOU WILL BE TESTED
ON YOUR ABILITY TO ACT
AS A SPOKESMODEL
FOR A PRETEND COSMETICS LINE
NAMED ANTM BEAUTY.
YOU WILL BE EVALUATED ON
HOW WELL YOU PRESENT YOURSELVES
FOR 60 SECONDS.
Sara: HI, YOU GUYS.
I'M HERE TO PROMOTE
MY NEW BEAUTY LINE,
ANTM BEAUTY.
WE HAVE
500 DIFFERENT COMBINATIONS,
SO WE ARE VERY VERSATILE.
SO YOU WALK INTO MY--
MY BEAUTY SALON,
I WILL HOOK YOU UP,
AND YOU WILL LOOK LIKE
TYRA BANKS.
AND IF YOU WANT TO SEND IT
AS A GIFT,
WE CAN HOOK YOU
UP WITH THAT AS WELL.
Janice: TIME.
Eric: YOU STARTED OFF
SO STRONG,
BUT THEN YOU GOT NERVOUS.
THAT'S WHEN YOU KINDA FELL
INTO THE HOMEGIRL THING.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, SARA,
YOU HAD
AN UNDERWATER PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST PICTURE.
Janice: WOW.
Eric: WHOA.
Janice: I DIG BICEPS
AND EVERYTHING,
BUT IT'S A LITTLE TOO BICEP-Y.
Tyra: LOOK AT THE INTENSITY
IN YOUR EYES, MISS SARA.
Nigel: YOU LOOK FANTASTIC.
YOUR EYES--
THE BEST I'VE SEEN THEM.
Sara: THANKS.
Janice: THESE GIRLS WANT
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
SO MUCH, THEY'RE ABLE
TO BREATHE UNDERWATER
TO GET THE TITLE, ANYTHING.
April: ANTM UNDERSTANDS
THAT EVERY WOMAN NEEDS
THEIR OWN CUSTOMIZED
BRAND OF MAKEUP,
AND WE ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT YOUR BODY IS IMPORTANT.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TESTED
ALL OF OUR MAKEUPS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE 100% ALLERGY-FREE.
Janice: I'D LIKE TO SEE
A LITTLE MORE WARMTH
IN YOUR EYES.
WHEN YOU'RE SELLING THE PRODUCT,
A LITTLE MORE LOVE COMING OUT.
Eric: IT WAS LIKE
WE WERE WATCHING AN INFOMERCIAL
FOR THE PRODUCT.
Tyra: IT SOUNDED LIKE
YOU WERE AN AUCTION, JUST...
(imitates auctioneer calling)
THERE WAS ABSOLUTELY
NO PERSONALITY,
AND IT DIDN'T MAKE ME LIKE YOU
AND SAY, "OH, I WANNA BE
LIKE APRIL."
OKAY. HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: WOW!
Eric: WOW.
Tyra: IT'S AMAZING.
I LOVE THE MUSCLE IN YOUR LEG.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU WERE JUST
IN A NORMAL STUDIO POSING.
YOU DON'T LOOK LIKE
YOU'RE UNDERWATER.
THAT IS REALLY HARD TO DO,
EVEN FOR PROFESSIONAL MODELS.
Xiomara: WE DO NOT TEST
ON ANIMALS.
I AM NOT FOR THE CRUELTY
OF ANIMALS.
WE ONLY TEST ON HUMANS.
UM, BUT, UH... (sighs)
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO... UH...
Nolé: I THOUGHT IT WAS
VERY POOR DELIVERY.
Eric: A LITTLE
SCATTERBRAINED.
Nigel: SOUNDED AS IF YOU WERE
SELLING SORT OF A CHEAP MAKEUP.
THIS IS
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
NOT AMERICA'S
NEXT AVERAGE MODEL.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT,
THIS IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: OH!
Nigel: WHAT HAPPENED THERE?
Nolé: THE MOUTH IS OPEN.
YOU WERE NOT CATCHING THE FISH.
THE FISH WERE JUST IN THE WATER.
YOUR EYES WERE CLOSED.
WE NEEDED YOUR EYES OPEN.
Shandi: ANTM BEAUTY
HAS CREATED A...
AND...
UM, THE NEW ANTM BEAUTY LINE
IS A HIP, NEW, SUPER-GLAM LOOK
THAT CAN MAKE ALL WOMEN
FEEL LIKE A SUPER TOP MODEL.
Nigel: SHANDI,
YOU JUST DIDN'T SELL IT TO ME.
YOU WERE TOO QUIET.
YOU LACKED CONFIDENCE.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, SHANDI,
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: FREAKY.
Nolé: YOU DID NOT WORK
THE BLOUSE.
YOU DID NOT WORK YOUR FACE.
YOU DID NOTHING BUT SINK
LIKE THE "TITANIC."
Nigel: THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THAT OBVIOUSLY YOU DID GET
THE PHOTOGRAPH.
Janice: ALL YOU NEED IS ONE.
Nolé: NO, WE DON'T.
I WANNA SEE A HUNDRED.
Nigel: YOU KNOW WHAT?
MAYBE THAT'S TRUE, NOLé,
BUT I THINK JUST THE WAY
YOU ARE HANDLING IT RIGHT NOW,
THIS IS IMPRESSING ME,
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE OTHER GIRLS
WOULD HAVE BURST INTO TEARS
WITH THAT KIND OF CRITICISM.
Janice: (laughs)
Catie: ANTM BEAUTY CUSTOMIZES
YOUR COLORS.
NO MORE SECOND-GUESSING
ONCE YOU GET IT HOME
AND REALIZING, YOU KNOW,
"I JUST SPENT $10
ON THIS FOUNDATION,
AND IT'S NOT MY COLOR."
Eric: YEAH, I HATE THAT.
Catie: I HATE THAT, TOO.
(laughs)
Nigel: YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
I JUST NEEDED TO HAVE
A LITTLE BIT MORE FORCE
AND POWER.
Tyra: HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: WHOA!
Tyra: GORGEOUS.
A LITTLE CROSS-EYED.
Janice: BODY ROCKS.
Tyra: BUT THE POSE IS
THE BEST ONE OUT OF EVERYBODY.
Janice: YEAH, THE POSE--
THE POSE IS INSANE.
I LOVE IT!
Mercedes: ANTM BEAUTY
IS REALLY FOR EVERYBODY.
IT'S FOR MY MOTHER,
WHO HAS WHITE AND FAIR SKIN,
OR IT'S FOR MY FATHER,
WHEN HE GOES OUT
AND DOES HIS DRAG QUEEN THING.
Janice: I LOVE THAT!
Tyra: (chuckles)
Janice: SO YOUR DAD DOESN'T
REALLY WEAR MAKEUP.
Mercedes: NO, NO.
GOD, HE'D KILL ME.
Janice: ALL IN ALL,
YOU ROCKED.
Tyra: YOU'RE ENGAGING,
YOU WERE YOUNG, FRESH,
AND WHEN I WAS WATCHING YOU,
YOU MAKE ME SMILE.
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Eric: MNH-MNH.
Janice: MISS BUBBLY!
YOU BUBBLED OUT.
Nigel: NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
IT'S NOT A GRABBING PICTURE.
Nolé: I WILL HAVE
TO DEFEND HER ON THIS.
YOU ARE A VISUAL ORGASM.
Yoanna: ANTM BEAUTY
IS A UNIVERSAL... (babbles)
IT HAS... ITS PACKAGING IS...
Eric: YOU WERE HAVING
A COMPLETE AND UTTER SHUTDOWN.
Tyra: HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Yoanna: OH, GOSH.
Janice: I THINK
IT'S THE WORST PICTURE
I'VE EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE.
YOUR HAIR LOOKS LIKE A COCKATOO
THERE AND HERE.
I MEAN, IT'S JUST, YOU KNOW...
Eric: IT LOOKS A LITTLE BIT
LIKE AN ADULT ULTRASOUND.
YOUR FACE AGAIN, THOUGH,
STILL, IT'S GORGEOUS.
IT'S ALWAYS GORGEOUS
WHEN IT'S PHOTOGRAPHED.
Camille: AS YOU MAY KNOW, UM,
I'M AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND I'M HERE TODAY
TO INTRODUCE TO YOU
OUR PRODUCT LINE.
LAST YEAR,
I WON THE COMPETITION
FOR AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND THE MAKEUP ARTISTS
THAT I MET--THEY USED
THE PRODUCTS ON MY FACE,
AND I REALLY LIKED IT.
(timer beeps)
Camille: WE TEST ALL OF OUR
PRODUCTS...
Nigel: YOUR TIME IS UP.
Camille: CAN I SAY
ONE THING, PLEASE?
Tyra: NO, THAT WAS THE TIME.
Nigel: THAT WAS THE TIME
YOU'RE GIVEN.
Eric: GROUND CONTROL
TO CAMILLE.
Janice: CAMILLE, FOR ME,
YOU WERE SLIGHTLY ARROGANT.
YOU SOUNDED PATHOLOGICAL,
AND IT WAS, LIKE, PSYCHOTIC
THAT YOU WON LAST YEAR, I FELT,
AND YOU MADE ME FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, SO THIS IS
YOUR PHOTO UNDERWATER.
Janice: BEAUTIFUL.
Nigel: IF YOU COULD BE
LIKE THIS IN PERSON AND HAVE
THAT KIND OF ELOQUENCE--
YOU WANNA WIN US OVER
WITH YOUR SWEETNESS AS WELL,
NOT JUST THIS SORT OF SHARPNESS.
Eric: INSANE.
♪♪♪
Tyra: OKAY, SARA.
Janice: I THINK SHE'S REALLY
COME INTO HER OWN.
I FEEL LIKE SHE LOOKS LIKE
AN EAST GERMAN SWIMMER.
Nigel: HER EYES
ARE A LOT BETTER.
I GUESS MY ONE NEGATIVE WITH HER
IS WHEN SHE WAS GIVING
THE SPEECH, SHE DROPPED IT INTO
THAT SORT OF GHETTO THING.
Tyra: THERE'S AN ART
TO USING THAT.
I DON'T THINK
SHE'S MASTERED IT--THE ART.
Nigel: NO, YOU'RE RIGHT.
Tyra: APRIL.
Eric: THIS IS INCREDIBLE
FOR APRIL.
Janice: "A" FOR
THE PHOTOGRAPH
BUT "D" TO "F" ON THE WAY
SHE SOLD THE MAKEUP TONIGHT.
Tyra: XIOMARA.
Nigel: IN ALL HONESTY,
I MEAN, FACIALLY,
SHE'S A PRETTY GIRL,
BUT SHE'S VERY HEAVY
IN THE BOTTOM PART OF HER JAW.
Eric: I THINK XIOMARA IS
ONE OF THE FEW GIRLS
WHO COULD BE DOING
THE COUTURE RUNWAYS IN PARIS.
Nolé: YOU BOTH ARE BLIND.
Nigel: ERIC.
Nolé: WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOU?
Eric: I THINK THAT THERE'S
POTENTIAL IN THAT.
Tyra: THE REASON WHY
SHE'S HERE IS HER ENERGY
WAS SO GREAT.
SHE JUST HAS THIS, YOU KNOW,
YOU KNOW, "LET ME AT 'EM,
LET ME AT 'EM,"
NEW YORK GIRL ATTITUDE.
I LOVE IT.
SHANDI.
Nolé: SHANDI.
HER FACIAL EXPRESSIONS
WERE ABSOLUTELY MORTIFYING,
BUT SHE SEEMED TO HAVE
POTENTIAL.
Nigel: MERCEDES.
WELL, A BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
SHE HAD A LOT OF CHARISMA.
Janice: HER FACE IS
REALLY DEAD IN THE PICTURE.
Tyra: SHE LOOKS LIKE
SHE'S COUNTING DOWN THE MINUTES,
LIKE, "IS IT OVER YET?
IS IT OVER?"
BUT HER PERSONALITY
IS SO ENDEARING.
YOANNA.
I THINK SHE LOOKS SO SERENE,
LIKE A BABY ABOUT TO BE BORN
IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
Eric: YOANNA LOOKS LIKE
SHE HAS SIX FINGERS.
IT LOOKS LIKE A LOBSTER CLAW.
Tyra: CATIE.
Nigel: FACE IS
A LITTLE STRANGE,
BUT I THINK SHE DID A GREAT JOB.
Nolé: SHE COULD BE
A LOT MORE EDGY,
A LOT MORE FASHION-FORWARD.
Tyra: CAMILLE.
Janice: SHE'S JUST SUCH
A DARN KNOW-IT-ALL.
Tyra: I DON'T THINK
THIS IS THE PLACE FOR HER.
THIS COMPETITION.
I THINK SHE NEEDS TO BE
SOMEWHERE TELLING PEOPLE
WHAT TO DO
RATHER THAN TAKING ADVICE.
Janice: I MEAN,
SHE TURNED ME OFF.
I MEAN, I'M GONNA VOTE HER
OUT TONIGHT.
♪♪♪
Tyra: I HAVE
EIGHT BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STANDING IN FRONT OF ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE SEVEN PICTURES
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE SEVEN PICTURES
REPRESENT THE SEVEN GIRLS
WHO WILL STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Tyra: SARA.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
MERCEDES.
CONGRATULATIONS.
APRIL.
APRIL, THIS IS
THE STRONGEST PICTURE
OF THE BUNCH,
BUT WHEN YOU TALK
AND HOW YOU'RE MOVING
YOUR HANDS SO, LIKE THIS,
IT'S NOT A LIKEABLE, WARM PERSON
THAT I REALLY WANNA
GET TO KNOW BETTER,
AND I WANT THEM TO SEE
THAT BEAUTIFUL PART OF YOU.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
YOANNA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
CATIE.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Tyra: SHANDI.
SHANDI, YOU ARE MAKING
THE MOST AMAZING TRANSFORMATION,
BUT THIS PHOTO WAS A FLUKE,
BECAUSE THIS IS
THE BEST OF THE WORST.
WHEN THERE'S
REALLY NEGATIVE ELEMENTS,
YOU NEED TO TRY TO LEARN HOW
TO TUNE ALL OF THAT OUT.
WILL CAMILLE AND XIOMARA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
Tyra: I ONLY HAVE
ONE PHOTO IN MY HANDS,
AND THE GIRL IN THIS PHOTO
WILL CONTINUE ON THE JOURNEY
TOWARD BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
CAMILLE, YOU HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH PEOPLE TELLING YOU
WHAT TO DO,
AND IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THAT, YOU'RE NOT GONNA
BE ABLE TO BE A TOP MODEL.
XIOMARA, THE JUDGES LOVE
YOUR PERSONALITY,
BUT ON PHOTO SHOOTS,
YOU LOSE YOUR FOCUS
AND DON'T TAKE DIRECTION WELL.
BUT NEVERTHELESS,
I'M ALL ABOUT A GIRL
WITH PERSONALITY.
Tyra: CAMILLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU, XIOMARA.
♪♪♪
Xiomara: I LOVE SHANDI
AND YOANNA AND APRIL
AND EVERYONE.
I LOVE YOU. I LOVE YOU.
TAKE CARE.
I DIDN'T WANNA BE ELIMINATED.
WHO WANTS TO BE ELIMINATED?
I DON'T WANNA GO HOME.
I LEARNED THAT YOU CAN NEVER
LISTEN TO ANYONE BUT YOURSELF.
GO WITH YOU.
DON'T TRY TO BE SOMETHING
THAT YOU'RE NOT.
BESIDES BEING BORN,
THIS IS THE BEST THING
THAT'S EVER HAPPENED TO ME.
♪♪♪
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
HERE'S WHAT'S COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
Yoanna: WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
WE'VE BEEN STUCK WITH 12 GIRLS.
IT'S TIME FOR SOME TESTOSTERONE.
Tyra: SOME GIRLS
ACT LIKE DRAMA QUEENS...
Shandi: I HATE YOU!
Camille: OH, MY GOD.
Tyra: BUT CAMILLE
MISSES HER CUE.
Camille: (stilted voice)
I DIDN'T BELIEVE IT.
IT'S TRUE. YOU ARE ALIVE.
Woman: I THOUGHT
IT WAS HORRIBLE.
(record needle scratches)
♪♪♪